explain to me dot dot dot the concept of
microtones do we ever use them in
western music it does show up in popular
music especially with instruments like
the guitar you can bend notes on the
guitar and trumpets clarinet and flutes
and things like this where you you have
control over where you put your finger
where you place the note an easy way to
explain microtones is through a game
that I often play just for fun I like
playing games for fun you take two notes
G and
E how many notes can you fit between
these two notes on the
piano there are two notes
between
right what happens if we try and squeeze
in more
notes
right you go forever these are all
microtones these are notes that you
can't find in the piano